today for the daily cancellation we have
a show that was made for this segment it
is destined to be canceled canceled here
and hopefully in a more literal sense as
well though on that latter point I don't
have much hope I think it's uh more
likely that this show will run for 45
seasons and Garner millions of devoted
fans because that's the kind of culture
we live in but the show uh which has
just been added to HBO Max is called
naked attraction and it's exactly what
it sounds like it's an uncensored full
frontal nude dating show reading for The
Hollywood Reporter it says quote one of
the UK's most infamous dating shows was
quietly added to the max streaming
service last week and it's already
causing quite a stir the streamer has
imported six seasons of naked attraction
a game show that promises to start where
a good date often ends naked in each
episode a single Chooser critiques and
eliminates six potential dates standing
on a stage by scrutinizing their fully
nude bodies which are gradually revealed
one part at a Time faces are revealed
last but only two potential dates Remain
the Chooser strips out of their own
close to giving the remaining two
contestants the opportunity to critique
them the final couple then go out on a
date with their clothes on the episodes
on Max are uncensored but I've added a
warning at the beginning of each episode
so revealing the face last is a nice
touch it uh you know in case you didn't
already get the message based on the
whole premise of the show The Point here
is to totally objectify these people
it's to remove their Humanity entirely
you're judging each individual body part
before you even see their faces
they are until that point nothing more
than
faceless collections of Limbs and organs
of course the participants are
volunteering for this objectification so
they're not victims the victim here is
society the culture which suffers yet
another blow
that's why as we're told some HBO Max
customers are not very happy to find
this garbage on their platform but
plenty of others unfortunately yet
predictably are thrilled quote many are
defending the show a quote despite the
nudity it isn't supposed to be
titillating or dramatic or anything the
contestants are just normal people
normal flaws and the format promotes an
open healthy discussion of sex with the
participants wrote a viewer on Reddit
that's because this is how you have a
healthiest conversation about sex you
have it naked on camera that's the best
way to have a health you know every
healthy conversation that's how you have
that's that's that that's the the the
beginning point for any healthy
conversation is that it happens naked on
camera
anyway a lot of Americans might actually
benefit from seeing this opined another
there's a surprising diversity of
contestants bodies and tastes talked
about pretty matter-of-factly and
another it's nice to see because the
media and xxs has conditioned us to see
bodies in a certain unrelatable way
usually too perfect an airbrush and on
ABC's The View on Monday Sunny Hosten
said uh I'm embarrassed to admit my
husband Emmanuel and I got so obsessed
with the show we binged it yesterday and
I learned things I've never heard of in
my life it was one of the most
fascinating things I've ever seen
yes fascinating is one way to describe
it another word you could use is
disgusting depressing dismal dystopian
lots of uh d words and just so you
understand how dismally dystopian this
is here's the censored version of the
trailer for the show watch
in this dating show we go back to basics
are you ready bring on and start we're a
good day often ends
[Music]
naked
let's look I've never been faced with
six no but I feel like I should have
done what do men and women really find
physically attractive wow this is
fantastic and could picking a partner
based solely on their natural beauty
help us find the one I've never met
anybody like this before and I don't
know where to live let's find out by
dating in Reverse who are you going to
pick see your date this is the hardest
decision of my life oh my God naked
attraction
so we see that the naked people are
literally kept in boxes and the lid on
the box opens slowly so each body part
is revealed and judged separately and
those rejected then must suffer the
humiliation of not only being rejected
but being rejected while naked in front
of an audience of thousands
it's the kind that you'd expect to exist
in the universe of some kind of
dystopian sci-fi film this is something
that would have made sense in Idiocracy
except it would have been a little too
dark for that movie and as it turns out
all too real
so what can we learn from this show um
well nothing at all obviously but a
couple things we already knew can come
into sharper focus and the first is that
of course we live in a horrifically
malformed and decayed culture in fact
it's decayed to such an extent that it
can barely be called a culture at all
you know if you leave the apple on the
counter for too long it'll start to rot
and if you let it rot for too long
eventually it'll not really be an apple
anymore it'll be nothing more than a
pile of putrid mush
and that's the stage that we've reached
with our culture we have reached putrid
mush stage we are existing not in a
culture but in the remnants of what was
once a culture a show uh like this could
not exist in a country that had any sort
of vibrant real culture
this can only grow out of a culture's
decomposing remains
um that's not to say a naked attraction
is somehow significantly worse than what
has come before it I mean there are
millions of reality dating shows and
they're all degenerate and stupid and in
terms of the nudity we live in a country
where millions of people have been
watching hardcore porn since they were
young children full frontal nudity in a
reality show it's almost quaint by
comparison which is why it's funny that
one of those comments on Reddit that
said you know Americans could really uh
yeah this is something they need to see
yeah you know because Americans aren't
seeing enough nudity that that's the big
problem in our in our society right now
is that Americans haven't seen enough
nude people
before giving our dog rough greens he
was so sad and lazy now he actually
enjoys his squeaky toys and playing
Fetch with his frisbee our pup stays are
filled with laughter exercise and
endless fun naturopathic under Dennis
black the founder of rough grains is
focused on improving the health of every
dog in America little did I know before
I got rough greens dog food is dead food
everybody knows that nutrition isn't
Brown it's green well you can let rough
grains boost your dog's food back to
life rough grains is a supplement that
contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't have to go out and buy
new dog food you just sprinkle rough
Greens on their food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving about rough
grains that supports healthy joints and
proves bad breath boosts energy levels
and so much more we are what we eat and
that goes for dogs too naturopathic Dr
Dennis black is so confident rough
greens will improve your dog's health
he's offering my listeners a free jump
start trial bag so your dog can try it a
free jump start trial bag can be at your
door in just a few business days go to
roughgreens.com Matt or call 844 rough
700 that's r u f f greens.com Matt or
call 844 rough 700 today
so this is not another stage in our slip
slide down the slippery slope we are at
the bottom of the slope and this is just
another thing getting tossed into the
muck
and this all sounds uh really Bleak and
and discouraging I realize but well it's
a bleak and discouraging thing I don't
know what else to tell you the good news
though and yes I am straining to come up
with the good news but but here's
something
that's that you can use
um these depraved idiotic dating reality
shows especially one like naked
attraction as a very accurate road map
towards healthy and productive dating
and I'm not suggesting that you actually
watch any of these shows I'm certainly
not suggesting that you model your
dating life after anything on these
shows they are a road map but they're an
inverted roadmap so you can look at what
they do
and just do the exact opposite of that
so consider the naked faceless people in
boxes being chosen based on a close
inspection of their bare body parts and
you can choose your date in exactly the
opposite kind of way you can take into
account the full person and by that I
don't mean their full naked body I mean
consider what sort of person
this is their value system their
character
is the person honest forthright
intelligent do we share the same
fundamental belief system are our basic
priorities and principles aligned
of course physical attraction is
important but it's only one ingredient
in the recipe that makes for a
successful relationship which leads to a
successful marriage that's the other
crucial factor that I'm pretty certain
doesn't come up in the naked people and
boxes show is that when you're dating
you should see it as a courtship process
leading towards marriage and you should
be looking for someone who've used
dating the same way again do the
opposite of what our decayed pseudo
culture suggests
which is easier said than done perhaps
but also it's the only way
and that's why HBO Max and their
dystopian naked dating show
is today canceled if you'd like to see
what else I have to say you can access
my full show by going to dailywire.com
or by going to the Matt wall Show
Twitter page hope to see you there
Godspeed